défi communiste ou communisants d'hommes
semblables les beaux
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous écouter
et scopeo l'observatoire politique je
suis lucas da silva cofondateur de
scopeo et je vous souhaite la bienvenue
sur ce septième épisode de notre série
l'entrevue politique aujourd'hui nous
sommes très heureux de recevoir monsieur
à nice la genève pour discuter avec lui
de finance internationale
mais avant tout je laisse la parole à
pierre vitaly également co-fondateur de
scopeo pour qu'ils puissent poser le
décor de ce podcast
merci lucas bonjour à celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent et surtout bonjour à vous
monsieur à nice la jeunesse bonjour vous
nous fait le plaisir de nous accorder
cette entrevue pour discuter ensemble de
finance internationale et des débats qui
émane des crises économiques que nous
avons traversées récemment en effet le
thème dans c de cet entretien portera
sur l'avenir de la finance mondiale mais
avant de démarrer l'entrevue monsieur à
nice la jeunesse je vous laisse vous
présenter pour ceux qui ne nous écoute
avec votre parcours particulier celui
d'un trader passé à la critique de la
finance d'accord donc en gros bond and
is lajnef j'ai été trader tout d'abord
la sté générale de 2001 à 2009 sur les
dérivés actions sur le bouc principal
qu'est celui de la france et ensuite je
suis allé à londres chez nous au maroc
japonais ce qui venait de racheter
lehman brothers
celle qui a fait faillite en 2008 et
donc moi je les ai rejoints juste après
en 2009 juste après le séisme
et ensuite je suis allé chez la barclays
qui est la deuxième banque britannique
encore une fois et j'étais responsable
du trading sur le flou dérivés très bien
merci alors pour commencer je vais je
vais citer une fameuse phrase de
françois hollande lors de son discours
du bourget en 2012 il expliqué mon
véritable adversaire n'a pas de nom n'a
pas de visage pas de partis
il ne présentera jamais sa candidature
il ne sera donc pas élu pourtant il
gouverne cet adversaire c'est le monde
de la finance alors de cette fameuse
phrase notre première question bien
évidemment la finance est elle
réellement si puissante at elle vraiment
le pouvoir
ou est ce un mythe vous libérer très
rapidement
grand banquier français des années 90
début des années 2000 qui donne une
définition de la finance il dit le
système financier l'ensemble des
institutions dans la matière première
est la tête
la finance et mais de la dette fait
circuler de la dette place de la dette
négocié de la dette
ok une fois qu'on sait ça la phrase de
françois hollande en fait simple du vent
parce que si on sait en même temps que
la création monétaire n'existe que si il
ya une création de dettes
donc si on enlève pas le création de
pouvoir de l'abus du pouvoir de la
création monétaire à la finance en fait
tous ces mots là reste des mots dans le
vent c'est à dire qu'on peut pas réguler
la finance c'est la finance qui régule
les hommes politiques au moment où le
monde économique parce que c'est eux qui
ont le pouvoir
un de créer de la monnaie de la louer
dans les activités qu'ils veulent
économique ou financière et en gros ils
ont quasiment un droit de vie ou de mort
sur chacun de nous
quand je dis de vie ou de mort pas
réelle vie ou de mort sociale et
économique
c'est à dire que si vous allez dans une
banque et que vos dossiers ne leur plaît
pas ils peuvent décider de ne pas vous
donner si la création monétaire est
nécessaire par le crédit et ils peuvent
faire en sorte que vous ne réussissez
pas dans votre vie à moins que vous
décidez d'aller vers le salariat
mais donc que ce soit les entreprises ça
soit les hommes politiques ou n'importe
qui quel agent économique dans cette
société nous sommes tous soumis d'une
façon ou d'une autre à la finance et si
on veut aller un cran plus loin si on se
dit mais en fait si le pouvoir de
création monétaire est donné aux banques
et au système financier
qu'est ce que ça veut dire dragon c'est
à dire que ce sont les seuls qui sont
capables de créer de la monnaie donc le
sens qu eric l'économie de quelle façon
créer cette monnaie ce n'est pas créer
n'importe comment semer s'est créé via
une tête et donc ils sont capables de
ramener à aujourd'hui les le travail
futur qu'on est capable de
alizée ok donc c'est une certaine avance
sur le temps qu'il réalise comme des
magiciens qu'une baguette magique et
cette avance qui dirait qu'ils arrivent
ce pouvoir incroyable qu'ils ont de
pouvoir ramener aujourd'hui notre argent
future prend faire de la monnaie
utilisable aujourd'hui en fait c'est
d'une certaine façon un commerce du
temps mais son commerce du temps des
pack gratuit
parce que il demande face à ce pouvoir
qu'il aurait conféré gratuitement ils
ont simplement une licence bancaire
face à ce pouvoir de création monétaire
de l'argent qu'ils n'ont même pas qui a
été créé à partir de rien ils demandent
des intérêts et ses intérêts là en fait
c'est quoi c'est je vais rembourser le
banquier mais je vais devoir travailler
un peu plus pour lui payer les intérêts
et le un peu plus par exemple en 2008 ça
représentait quasiment 20% des richesses
créées en france en ce moment ça tombe
plutôt entre 8 et 10%
ok et donc c'est une part énorme qui lui
est donné et si on considère que 8 ou 10
% des crèches des richesses créées sont
donnés aux banques
on peut aussi considérer comme certains
le pensent que c'est un vol du temps
donc voilà tout ça c'est de des paroles
politiques
françois hollande a été démagogique
d'ailleurs on le voit même politiquement
c'est lui qui a placé macron et c'est
lui qui a été la parfaite transition
avec ce nouveau gouvernement et ce
nouveau président qui est au service des
banques dans cette première réponse
finalement vous vous êtes en train de me
dire que la politique est en quelque
sorte servile il ya une soumission de la
classe politique envers le monde de la
finance et finalement les élections ne
servirait pas à grand chose
bien sûr parce que alors là j'ai parlé
du commerce du temps et du vol de du
temps mais il ya une autre paire version
qui est liée à la création monétaire par
le crédit c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'expo nantiat lité du taux d'intérêt
c'est à dire que le taux d'intérêt est
de nature exponentielle et qu'est ce que
c'est à dire que ce soit de nature est
exponentielle sais que ça va faire un
effet boule de neige et au fil du temps
les richesses petit à petit vont
s'accumuler sur quelques agents
économiques qui vont devenir de plus en
plus puissants économiquement d'abord
parce que ils concentrent sur une
richesse incroyable et petit à petit
cette ce pouvoir économique va se
transformer en pouvoir médiatique mais
aussi on pouvoir politique et ce sont
les gens alors toth parle lui de caste
stato financière c'est très vrai en
france un peu moins vrai dans les pays
anglo-saxons où l'état quand même moins
de place que justement ces mastodontes
économiques
mais si on regarde bien ce sont ces gens
là qui décide qui seront ceux qui nous
gouvernerons plus tard par le pouvoir
justement des médias du financement des
partis politiques etc
mais vous qui connaissez bien le monde
de la finance comme vous l'avez dit en
introduction et dans votre présentation
vous avez baigné dedans pendant de
nombreuses années
pouvez vous nous décrire selon vous les
vertus d'un tel système qui paraît
souvent si instable si bancal parce que
si je pose cette question on comprend
mal pourquoi notre économie se trouve si
dépendante de la santé de la finance
et pourquoi les banques centrales et les
états ils tiennent autant à s'assurer
que la finance se porte bien ça c'est
une très bonne question
si le capitalisme il a supplanté le
communisme c'est pour une bonne raison
c'est que 1 premièrement il fait passer
la liberté avant tout la liberté
d'entreprendre et ça c'est vital pour
l'homme l'homme est né
par nature libre donc il a besoin
d'avoir sa liberté
le problème de la justice du monde de la
finance c'est que d'abord parlons du bon
côté le bon côté c'est aussi quand vous
endettez des gens en gros moi j'ai la
joie un peu la monnaie et le crédit etc
comme où l'économie comme le
fonctionnement du corps humain
en gros imaginons quant à la circulation
du sang
quand on regarde c'est quoi le business
du crédit business de la dette
c'est comme si on avait implanté dans le
corps humain un organe qui accélère le
sens mais qu'il accélère de plus en plus
jusqu'à ce qu'à un moment hyper mais
avant qui pète c'est formidable pourquoi
parce que le crédit en fait c'est une
avance sur le temps donc et le crédit
aussi à cause du caractère exponentiel a
besoin d'une croissance infinie
sinon il peut pas fonctionner et donc en
début de cycle usuraires c'est à dire
quand on commence le début du cycle qui
a commencé avec breitenau de 144 à
fréquenter fait table rase qui est 50
millions de morts est dédé quand on a
commencé ce cycle usuraires tout se
passait bien
c'est en fin de cycle qu'on voit les
catastrophes de la finance pourquoi
parce que ça accélère ça accélère
tellement jusqu'à ce que les corps lâche
jusqu'à ce que les inégalités sont au
maximum jusqu'à ce qu'on voit que cette
recherche de croissance infinie
en fait créer des désastres écologiques
des désastres humains et je ne suis pas
expert en la question mais le virus est
ce que ce sont pas des décors sur
stressés qui courent constamment après
le temps qui aurait lâché
est-ce que déjà des gens bien portants
qui lie qui prennent le temps qu'ils
vivent avec au jour le jour et ces
terrains ne serait pas plus armés contre
un virus c'est une question qu'il faut
se poser
merci et justement c'est la finance et
pour certains un formidable outil qui
permet la croissance économique pour
d'autres comme vous l'avez dit a peut
être responsable d'inégalités
d'instabilité économique et cette
deuxième vision très négative et est
très présente dans notre société alors
qu'elle
sont les voies éventuelle de
contestation possible pour les citoyens
pour les classes populaires
est ce qu'il existe des possibilités de
révolution à l'échelle internationale
contre la finance est-ce que
éventuellement ce soit nécessaire et on
voit avec la sphère gamestop peut-être
les crypto monnaie est ce que ce sont
des outils pertinents pour pressé de
changer ce système que vous critiquez on
vient d'expliquer alors tout ce qu'il ya
instabilité une qualité est inhérent
même au système c'est à dire que tant
que la monnaie est tué de la dette et de
la dette avec intérêt on va constamment
courir après le temps et vouloir courir
après la croissance pouvoir payer les
intérêts justement est allé dans un
monde de plus en plus instable encore
une fois c'est l'idée de la boule de
neige qui déboule de la montagne au
début ce sympathique à la fin devient
trop énormes avancées avant de s'éclater
en bas de la vallée et donc qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire ça qui est
incroyable c'est que s'il ya quelqu'un
de gentil qui vient avec un coup de
baguette magique qui décide de dire
quand vous savez quoi vous êtes tous
stressés
vous êtes tous endettés parce que les
ménages et les entreprises sans
énormément d'été si on dit fahy qui
vient et qu'il annule toutes les dettes
malheureusement il y aura plus de
monnaie en circulation c'est à dire que
notre monnaie n'est défini que par la
dette
donc même c'est un gentil monsieur qui
viendrait le prince leurs baux de brunei
qui viendraient et qui effacerait toutes
nos dettes en fait détruire et notre
économie
donc on est là on semble être dans une
impasse
l'autre chose c'est que on peut essayer
de 2,2 de réduire un peu la voilure
par exemple en s'attaquant aux à tout ce
qui est gâchis mais même ça si on
s'attaque au gâchis ben en fait on
s'attaque aussi au pib parce que le pib
s'en fout est-ce que ce qui a été vendu
et manger ou pas été consommés ou pas et
si on s'attaque au pib qu'on le réduit
notre système qui est encore une fois
fondée sur la dette avec intérêt ne peut
pas fonctionner il a besoin de
constamment d'être en croissance donc on
peut se dire aussi bas les gens ce qu'il
pourrait faire 6
le sens qu eric ce marché cette économie
c'est la dette
on pourrait faire en sorte que les gens
essaient de moins s'endetter le plus
possible quoi mais même ça s'ils font ça
le le marché l'économie n'est pas
capable de vivre en décroissance parce
que sa monnaie ne le permet pas encore
une fois elle a besoin de cette
croissance constante
on est face à une impasse en fait et ce
qu'ils ont compris un peu ce sont tous
ces jeunes [ __ ] les adeptes tous ceux qui
y croient ou cryptome honnête mais
encore une fois je suis persuadé que la
manu c'est ce qui est le lions de la
société et c'est ce qui fait lien entre
chaque citoyen est donc je ne peux pas
moi concevoir que la monnaie soit
totalement décentralisé jeu grande une
monnaie qui soit centralisé qui soit
commune mais pour ça il faudrait en
faire en sorte que justement repenser la
monnaie et faire en sorte
l'art est de reposer sur la dette et
avec intérêts il faut justement repenser
un aixois ce qu'on appelle libre de
dettes et comment on peut imaginer une
monnaie qui soit décentralisée et qu'ils
soient libérés de cette logique de la
dette parce que il ya des penseurs il y
avait pu avoir des économistes qui
imaginent une monnaie propre à chaque
échelon une monnaie à l'échelle locale
qui puisse réconcilier les citoyens des
monnaies un petit peu indépendante de
des systèmes des banques centrales alors
comment on peut imaginer une monnaie qui
reste centralisée mais qu'ils puissent
échapper à la logique de la dette que
vous critiquez c'est possible on peut
avoir
petit à petit ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il
faut faire une dialyse monétaire de la
monnaie actuelle c'est à dire que de nos
jours la monnaie actuelle elle n'existe
que si elle ne dette
ok s'il faudrait faire en sorte c'est
petit à petit transformé cette monnaie
par une autre monnaie qui serait il faut
l'imaginer comme des pièces comme des
jeux
comme des billets hockey qui est
introduite sans dette
par exemple je donne un exemple très
simple
l'état français depuis à peu près 40 ans
sans dette chaque année d'à peu près 3%
de la richesse créée ok pourquoi parce
que constamment
il dépasse son budget et il a besoin que
c'est difficile d'aller sur les marchés
emprunter de l'argent on pourrait
décider démocratiquement que chaque
année 3% de la masse monétaire soient
créés livres de dettes et servent
viendont à subventionner l'état pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait moins de
pression une société de fiscal et que le
budget de l'état soit plus souple hockey
qu'on facilite la tâche à l'état ça
c'est une façon d'introduire cette
monnaie libre de dettes dans la société
est alors cet argent circulerait comme
des beats conne comme lors de façon
libre cet argent ne meurent jamais parce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la
monnaie actuelle meurt meurt quand
allait rembourser à chaque fois que les
banques commerciales et met un crédit
elle crée de la monnaie mais à chaque
fois que les gens rembourser ce crédit
en fait ils détruisent de la monnaie
c'est pour ça qu'on est dans une course
8 en avant constante et c'est pour ça
que on est constamment constamment dans
le besoin de créer du crédit créer de la
croissance
constamment et donc cette money libre de
dettes est là l'intérêt que sa vie est
infinie donc elle ne meurt jamais ça
aussi c'est une solution possible
et à l'heure où on est au 21ème siècle
on peut penser qu' on puisse
démocratiquement votées pour une monnaie
qui est justement soit un libre de
dettes de décider de la création
monétaire par an parce que si on laisse
les taddei débat ça va être open bars et
ça va être infinie est là
jean pas perdre de sa valeur donc on
peut dire que chaque année l'état a
droit à une dotation de 3 % de la masse
monétaire ce qui fait aujourd'hui à peu
près 3% de la richesse créée et ça on
peut dire que c'est un dividende social
ok et donc voilà les critères de cette
monnaie ce serait une monnaie libre de
dettes avec une création mode de
monétaire de 3% par an qui le dividende
social et à côté de ça on peut pas
empêcher les gens de se prêter de
l'argent entre eux parce que à côté de
ça on a besoin que cette monnaie libre
de dettes circulent est ce que si elle
ne circulent pas c'est une catastrophe
pour l'économie
il n'y a rien de pire pour l'économie
que la thésaurisation la thésaurisation
pour ceux qui savent pas ce que c'est
c'est quand les gens accumulent des
richesses et ne le dépensent pas et on a
tendance à vouloir faire ça dans une
société où il ya très peu d'inflation
et justement je vais rebondir sur cette
cette éventuelle création de deux
monnaies justement dont vous parlez avec
ce risque de perte de valeur est
aujourd'hui la dépendance de nos états à
d'autres pays à d'autres font justement
de cette dette et le liés à l'actualité
puisque la crise du co en un virus à a
contraint les états européens à ceux sur
endettés et certains évoquent la
suppression de cette dette est ce que ça
vous semble possible de de rayer comme
ça d'un trait ses dettes accumulées lors
lors du camp en un virus ça c'est une
bonne question c'est que il faut revenir
juste un peu en arrière c'est que par
exemple quand on parle du cycle
plusieurs heures alors je vais très vite
un gimmick ça a commencé avec la fin de
la deuxième guerre mondiale avec brad
hand 144 mais il ya une date qui s'est
passé 171 ok c'est la fin des accords de
bretton woods c'est à dire que à ce
moment là nixon président américain et y
voit là le le dollar n'est plus adossé à
la roquette à partir de là on a une
libération des cours des devises et des
cours des matières premières qui a
apporté une hyper financiarisation de
l'économie
ok et les banques ont commencé à être
nationalisé un peu partout surtout en
france et a poussé sur le crédit et
surtout le plus d'immobilier et ça nous
a amené à la crise de 2008
ok et à partir de là à partir de là
crise de 2008
on était face à une montagne de dettes
et avec des populations qui étaient
incapables justement de pouvoir payer
ses dettes et ses intérêts quand je les
dis rien que les intérêts c'était 21 %
de la richesse créée c'est hallucinant
parce que si on veut comparer par
exemple hôpital public c'est 3% de la
richesse créée l'éducation nationale
c'est 3% de la richesse créée maximum en
jeu
au delà du vrai budget c'est plutôt deux
et demi pour l'éducation nationale et si
on regarde par exemple en france combien
il ya de gens qui travaillaient du scan
surmas mal c'est 1,2 million pareil pour
l'hôpital public 1,2 million de gens de
fonctionnaires travaillent à l'hôpital
public mais 360000 banquet sucre en 2008
va 20 % de la richesse créée c'est
hallucinant c'est à dire ils sont ils
sont trois fois moins voire quatre fois
moi même trois fois et demi moins mais
pourtant il
ils prennent en richesse six fois plus
que l'hôpital public où l'éducation
nationale ok et donc comment on a
répondu à cette crise parce qu'à ce
moment là
tous devaient faire faillite tout vu
s'effondrer et ses seins les états qui
sont venus qui ont aidé d'abord la
finance et ensuite c'est la bce et à une
un problème de dette de montagne de
dettes n'a créé à une autre montagne de
dettes qui sont les dettes des états et
le bilan de la bce qui ont grossi sa
tête son sens pas fait son passif
augmente son actif aussi mais sans
passif augmente et donc on a répondu à
une montagne de dettes par une autre
montagne
le net en espérant que tout ça allait
tenir et que par un coup de baguette
magique de création monétaire de la bce
tous nos problèmes allaient être réglé
le problème de sa la façon dont s'est
injecté parce que alors c'est pour ça
que je suis obligé d'expliquer une fois
que la blessure créer de l'argent
comment elle injecte dans les marchés
dans la dans l'économie elle ne
l'injectent pas directement à la jette
d'abord sur les marchés financiers et
quand elle la jette dans le marché c'est
ce qui est bien c'est que ça ne crée pas
de l'inflation des prix à la
consommation
ça crée de l'inflation seulement des
actifs financiers et immobiliers c'est à
dire là les actions les obligations et
l'immobilier et donc si elle injecte là
bas les prix des actions le prix de
l'immobilier montent et donc les
possédants deviennent de plus en plus de
plus en plus riches
c'est à dire que les adeptes des 1 du
plus grand nombre devient la richesse
elle à son miroir qu'est la richesse des
plus riches est en fait en exacerbe les
inégalités de richesse et là il se passe
un problème c'est que maintenant énorme
et pédago casse ce sur la tête parce que
on a par exemple 130 ou à dire 125% du
pub en dette publique
tous les ménages en corpus et les
entreprises encore plus endettée
chacun d'eux lors de 150% du pipe et
donc s'il ya une augmentation selon de 1
% des taux d'intérêt ok collectivement
on devra rendre quasiment 4% de la
richesse créée à ceux qui nous ont
embêtés
mais le problème c'est de savoir être
comprendre qu'on il nous endetter nous
endetter à partir de rien c'est à dire
que quand les banques créent de la
monnaie pour endetter les états les
ménages ah non pas le capital qu'elles
prêtent elles ont une toute petite
fraction en fonds propres donc à sont
capables de créer quasiment 97% d'argent
à partir de rien et de leloup de le
prêter
ou aux entreprises et aux ménages et aux
états et donc comment on pourrait faire
pour que tout ce monde là soit mois
d'été c'est ce qu'ont fait les imériens
où c'est ce qu'ont fait les gens dans la
bible c'est le jubilé c'est à dire qu'à
un moment il va falloir effacer des
dettes pour que tout le monde respire un
peu
et même si comptablement ça a l'air
d'être un tour de passe passe
politiquement c'est une énorme bouffée
d'air et la façon de faire c'est
justement d'annuler la dette publique
qui est détenu par la bce sachant que
par exemple pour la france c'est la
banque de france qui détient cette dette
publique et c'est s'est fait
équitablement entre tous les pays
chaque banque nationale a acheté
équitablement la part de dette publique
et de multinationales de son état ça
veut dire que c'est nous avons nous
notre dette les français notre dette
publique on la face à la bce mais en
réalisant la face à la banque de france
et la banque de france appartient à 100%
à l'état donc ça revient au même c'est à
dire que c'est poche gauche proche
droite nous pouvons de l'annuler mais
les gens vont dire mais si on l'a nul à
quoi ça sert mais ça sert politiquement
en fait parce qu'on le voit la bce n'est
pas neutre la bce ne travaille pas dans
l'intérêt du peuple
la bce travail dans l'intérêt des
banques son pdg le gouverneur de la
banque de france par exemple qui est une
antenne de la bce c'est l'ancien pdg de
sce l'ancien numéro 2 de bnp c'est celui
qui a fait du lobbying au mois de
décembre 2020 pour que les banques
puissent enfin payer des dividendes et
en même temps en décembre 2020 en même
temps les passants à la radio à la télé
c'est le même qui passait son temps à
dire que les français vont devoir payer
travailler plus et qu'il va falloir tôt
ou tard payer cette dette
cette dette publique et que et s'il le
fallait il faudrait justement passé par
de l'austérité budgétaire
c'est des coupes dans les services
publics ou des hausses d'impôts voilà
donc il vaut mieux politiquement annulé
la dette publique qui est détenu par
notre cher banque de france et c'est
vrai qu'on appartient à tous on le voit
dans votre réponse mais parfois on a du
mal à faire le lien quand quand on voit
ces chiffres ou quand on évoque la dette
publique dans les médias on a du mal à
faire le lien entre ces d'être c'est aux
intérêts des filles et par la banque
centrale européenne et le quotidien des
français le quotidien du peuple on a du
mal à faire ce lien parfois et c'est
bien que vous appréciez pour qu'on
puisse comprendre moi je vais rester sur
le sur le sujet de la dette si vous le
voulez bien et on va parler notamment de
la crise de 2008 que vous avez un petit
peu évoquée est-ce que selon vous c'est
la politique qui doit reprendre le
pouvoir face à la finance
parce que si je pose cette question
c'est qu'on a parfois le sentiment
surtout justement depuis la crise de la
dette dans la zone euro à partir du
début des années 2010 surtout et plus
généralement la crise des dettes
souveraines que les états sont de plus
en plus impuissants face à la finance et
que c'est finalement la finance qui
contrôle en quelque sorte les pouvoirs
politiques alors que faire pour sortir
de cette spirale infernale annuler les
dettes comme vous l'avait préconisé ou
existe-t-il d'autres d'autres voies et
d'autres voies possibles mais l'image
que je donne pour 2008 parce que je les
ai vécus dans le coeur du cyclone à
l'intérieur c'est j'ai l'impression
qu'on on était à l'agonie dans les
banques et que notre survie elle ne
tenait que aux états et ensuite que la
banque centrale fed à la bce et c est
l'image que j'ai vraiment fait les
banques la finance
on était en train de se noyer dans un
fleuve un torrent et que les états et la
banque centrale nous ont sauvés mis
leurs mains et nous ont sauvés et une
fois qu'on est et alix à l'extérieur
d'une certaine façon les banques et la
finance et les to say say say say
spéculateurs qui ont été spéculé sur les
états du sud était en balance et les
états dans le fleuve
c'est vraiment cette image là que j'ai
demandé et je pense que n'importe qui de
sérieux là aussi c'est que on a poussé
la grèce la première dans le fleuve
il était en train d'emprunter 25 30 % le
portugal à 12 % l'italie a vu %
l'espagne 10%
et là il a fallu que la banque centrale
agisse énormément mais d'un côté elle a
sauvé les états ce qui est super en
baissant justement les taux d'intérêt
alors il faut faire attention à la
banque centrale normalement avant 2008
en avait le droit
elle avait qu'un seul levier en fait
c'étaient les taux d'intérêt court terme
c'est à dire au jour le jour quand les
banques déposent de l'argent dans les
coffres de la banque centrale c'est là
où la banque centrale pouvait décider du
taux directeur
ok ou du tout des baux etc mais ça n'a
pas marché ce n'était pas suffisant
ils ont mis les taux à zéro ou voir un
peu négative il savait ça a aidé pas le
système financier
donc ce qu'ils ont fait et c'est
complètement nouveau ils ont créé de la
monnaie à partir de rien et ils sont mis
à aller dans les marchés financiers pour
acheter les dettes publiques et ça c'est
mécanique
quand ils achètent des dettes publiques
des obligations des titres de démission
émises par des états eh ben ça fait
baisser les taux d'intérêt à plis site
et donc les taux d'emprunt futur ces
nouveaux gains d'une certaine façon
là on sort du mythe des marchés
efficients
parce que la banque centrale est censé
être un acteur neutre qui est là juste
pour surveiller de loin ce qui se passe
mais une fois qu'il va dans les marchés
et qui commence à lui même avoir des
positions c'est fini il n'est plus
neutre
il a des positions et donc c'est un
acteur parmi les autres en lamy avec
nous dans ce tour en de ce torrent de
boue et pour l'instant c'est à peu près
bien parce que il ne possède que 25% des
dettes publiques et il a encore de la
marge
mais il va avoir un moment où il
détiendra combien de 45 ans 60% des
dettes émises par les états et donc on
sera dans une logique quasiment
de communisme pour les riches c'est à
dire que petit à petit les banques
centrales sont obligés à chaque pas de
passer par les marchés financiers vont
créer des bulles financières qui sont
très très dangereux pour la société et
surtout ils vont exacerber les
inégalités de richesse donner du pouvoir
encore plus aux plus riches pouvoir
politique et médiatique et j'ai aussi en
même temps exaspéré le peuple leur le
frustrer socialement on ne voit alors
moi qui suis sur twitter je le vois
quotidiennement mais ça va tenir jusqu à
ce qu aux jo ça va péter
rien n'est gratuit en fait donc quand on
crée de l'argent à partir de rien qu on
la jette quelque part et que cet argent
ne fait face à aucune richesse créée au
final ça va créer du désordre
alors merci vous avez expliqué très
clairement et assez en même temps
simplement les différents problèmes pour
qu'on puisse comprendre les difficultés
liées à la finance et vous parliez de
jeu reprend vos mots ça va péter l'effet
boule de neige
l explosion à la fin est ce qu'on peut
envisager des solutions pour éviter
d'arriver à ces difficultés
sur 8 mois c'est d'avoir tort donc on
est lucide parce que mathématiquement on
se rend compte qu'il ya des effets
d'expérience yale les boules de neige et
que l'on sait que dans un monde fini ça
ne peut que péter hockey et mais l'idée
c'est dire mais comment on peut sortir
de ça donc il y a le jubilé qui permet
un peu de la tête donc le fait de
réduire une partie de la dette publique
qui permet un peu
de desserrer l'étau mais d'une force
d'une certaine façon c'est du
rafistolage c'est pas une solution à
long terme viable ce qu'il faudrait
c'est par exemple repenser comment on
peut prendre intelligent reprendre
intelligemment le pouvoir de création
monétaire donc tout à l'heure je vous ai
parlé de vraiment d'une solution qu'il
est viable qui est possible mais qui
demande énormément d'efforts politiques
et de compréhension des gens qu'il est
celle de la monnaie est libre de dettes
avec une création monétaire qui
subventionne l'état et comme je le dis
et le risque d'une telle monnaie qui ne
meurent pas c'est d'arrêter à la
paralysie de la monnaie est ce qu'on
appelle la thésaurisation donc pour
pallier à cette théorisation il ya un
économiste un peu iconoclaste du début
du 20e siècle
silvio gesell qui a donné l'idée de
fonte de l'harmonie de monnaies
fondantes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire cher que si
vous n'utilisez pas votre monnaie nous
avez 100 euros en compte dans votre
compte en banque si vous n'utilisez pas
le sens logo vous perdez un centime par
jour de la semaine et donc au fil de
l'année vous perdez à peu près
l'équivalent de 2 euros 60
grosso modo et cette fonte de la monnaie
fait en sorte que si vous n'utilisez pas
votre argent
cet argent va aller vers les plus
pauvres et puis démunis et pourront
utiliser de l'argent qu'on leur mette
dans le circuit économique
et ça pousse aussi à l'investissement
pourquoi parce que les gens vont vouloir
éviter de perdre et de paix de cette
taxe nous on vouloir aller à investir
dans des projets économiques ou prêter à
l'état ou à des multinationales à des
taux d'intérêt très bas pour éviter de
payer cette fonte et le fait que
cette fonte de 2,2 à peu près à 2,6
annuel % annuel fait en sorte aussi qu'
on est moins dans l'effet boule de neige
oui elles sont pas des taux négatifs
l'attention c'est vraiment une taxe sur
la monnaie l'argent est redistribué aux
pauvres mais quand on le prétend le prêt
à 0 ou très proches de zéro ce qui fait
que on n'est plus dans l'effet boule de
neige
on avait près 2008 où les taux étaient
autour de 4 5%
donc ça c'est une solution politique
mais qui demande énormément de
compréhension et des forces politiques
après il ya des solutions un peu
intermédiaire est par exemple une des
solutions c'est alors ça là je lui
donnais je vais donner deux solutions
qui y sont déjà la première sa
nationalisation des banques
c'est de se dire si les banques créent
de la monnaie à partir de rien ils ont
très peu de capital face à toute menace
est mené créé à partir de rien si elle
est créé à partir de rien c'est calé à
tout le monde parce qu'elle est à
personne en fait donc elle est à tout le
monde c'est de la monnaie d'intérêt
public
donc on est d'accord que les banques
sont responsabilisés sur cet argent mais
on le voit quand les banques pète comme
en mars 2014
en 2008 octobre 2008 ou comment mars
2020 à la fin ce sont les états la bce
sont eux qui mettent la main à la poche
et ce sont eux qui se sauve les banques
donc on est en dehors du mythe du
capitalisme qui dit que oui les banques
font de l'argent mais elles prennent du
risque en fait elles ne prennent plus de
risques parce que nous supportons le
risque collectivement donc à partir de
là on pourrait dire ben on fait comme au
sortir de la deuxième guerre mondiale en
1945 en de gaulle a nationalisé
quasiment toutes les banques
commerciales et on peut décider de dire
voilà les banques commerciales vont être
nationalisées et l'argent qu'elles
feront et ben sera servira justement à
des investissements type keynésien de
l'état pour relancer l'économie
ok ça c'est une solution possible il ya
une solution intermédiaire
et qui est redoutable parce qu'elle
utilise les codes de la haute finance
et cette solution est de dire bon goût
vous savez quoi on va garder les banques
privées parce qu'en fait qu'on s'est
privé est la liberté d'action et c'est
que et à la possibilité de gagner un peu
plus d'argent et d'être intéressé à la
croissance qui est réalisé et non pas de
la 2de d'en faire profiter l'état qui
peut se comporter de façon très
sélective et donc ce qu'ils ont ce qu'on
peut décider de se dire on va répliquer
le modèle des fonds spéculatifs
c'est-à-dire que le en fait quand un
investisseur le relais sans euro il on
doit 1 euros par an de frais de gestion
ok et si par exemple ce fonds
spéculatifs et du 10% avec leurs 100
euros ils gardent 12 euros il retourne 8
oraux à l'investisseur privé et donc en
gros ce que ça fait ça fait que l'argent
est partagé entre l'investisseur et le
fonds spéculatifs et pendant peut
décider de mettre en place des véhicules
pareil c'est à dire qu'on dit que les
banques gèrent notre argent
collectivement elles ont droit à 1% des
encours de crédit quelle crise
en ce moment c'est à peu près de 1200
milliards donc ça ferait 22 milliards
pour faire fonctionner les trois cent
soixante mille employés de banque ce qui
est ce qui est en ligne
si on fait des proportionnalité avec
ceux qui travaillent pour l'hôpital
public ou pour l'éducation l'éducation
nationale mais en plus on va leur dire
sur l'argent qu'ils vont faire mais
pourront regarder 20 % et le
redistribuer soient eux mêmes ou salarié
ou soit aux actionnaires je pense qu'il
est ça c'est une solution intermédiaire
est qui et qui utilise les codes du
de la finance et qui est redoutable
parce que elle et elle colle à la
réalité c'est que si les banques jouent
avec notre argent ils peuvent nous
retourner au moins 80 % des profits
khalfa qu'elles font surtout que quand
elle l derijck hanter à une crise c'est
nous qui mettons à la main à la poche
donc c'est vraiment le risque est
supporté par nous et les profits en ce
moment profit de kahel donc il faut
rééquilibrer et ramener un peu si ce qui
se pratique déjà dans la hotte haute
finance justement on va on va peut-être
rester sur ces sur ses solutions à
apporter au monde de la finance après
une première partie très pessimiste sur
le constat que vous avez apporté à la
finition la pessimiste d'un s'est passé
6 me c'est juste et réaliste
oui c'est ça on en parlera dans un ou
deux ans tu verras si c'est réaliste au
pessimisme et on ne bouge pas jacqueline
peu d'espoir justement si on n'évolue
pas si on n'apporte pas des solutions à
ce système ça peut laisser envisager un
avenir peu optimiste et justement grâce
à ses solutions que vous proposez on
peut imaginer un avenir un peu plus
optimiste pour les citoyens pour le
peuple et notre pays en de manière
générale j'imagine que vous avez
conscience que votre vision de
l'économie un petit peu hétérodoxe en
tout cas c'est pas celle qui est la plus
partagée chez les économistes et surtout
j'ai envie de dire dans les médias dans
la vision de l'économie qui nous a le
plus promu comment on fait si grâce aux
débats grâce et la discussion grâce aux
échanges
votre vision d'économie elles
l'emportent comment on fait pour la
mettre en place comment on fait pour la
mettre en oeuvre
est ce que on doit je sais pas vous êtes
très critique envers la bce alors est-ce
qu'on doit sortir l'union européenne est
ce qu'on peut être indépendant et mettre
en place notre propre mode notre propre
doctrine économique sans avoir l'accord
de l'union européenne ou est-ce que
c'est nécessaire de sortir l'union
européenne façon de l'union européenne
c'est une union qui a été créée autour
des bancs de la finance et des marchés
donc et des multinationales
c
mignon des marchés en fait c'est pas une
union des nations ou des peuples c'est
une union des marchés financiers de la
finance et donc on est un peu pris au
piège par les traités les traités ont
été très bien écrit c'est très difficile
d'en sortir par exemple quasiment
impossible que la banque centrale passe
directement par les états pour les
financer alors ils font tout un chenil
bic en ce moment avec le qi passe par
les marchés les banques prêtent aux
états la bce vient juste derrière on
peut en payant les étapes et des
commissions aux banques la bce fait
gagner quelques tito banques
commerciales etc
hashmi le big de folie parce qu'ils ont
de respecter les traités européens et
donc c'est très difficile et ce qu'il
faut faire c'est aller au bras de fer
c'est à dire que on ne faut pas qu'ils
aient un maquereau qui est probant
profinance qui a il discutait que
l'union européenne ne sera pas possible
ils vont rester dans ce schéma fermé
donc il faut y aller et essayer de
changer les choses de l'intérieur
et si c'est pas possible d'un sûr qu'il
faudra en sortir il faut d'abord donner
la chance aux changements à l'intérieur
et et le comment ils y arriver c'est
encore une fois c'est d'une certaine
façon faire d énormes seins énormes et
un général justement de du système
monétaire et bancaire et d'en changer
les règles avec par exemple
l'introduction de la monnaie est libre
de dettes que la bce
d'autres et les états et ça c'est le
premier point est le deuxième point
c'est le
la la la la smart nationalisation dont
j'ai parlé des banques et de dire
maintenant ça va être un partenariat
privé et avec un win win
c'est à dire que 80% de l'argent voir
revenir au trésor public
avec aussi une introduction de
démocratisation des allocations aux au
ban par exemple on n'est pas obligé
d'allouer une plus d'argent possible à
la banque qui a eu la meilleure
performance qui nous a apporté le plus
d'argent pour le budget c'est on peut
décider que 30 % de l'allocation réalisé
par l'état par les gens qui nous
gouvernent par l'assemblée nationale par
exemple et 70% le soir par des gens au
moment où ils remplissent leur feuille
d'impôt leur feuille d'imposition et il
décide
voilà moi je veux que ma paraguay tous
soient allouées aux crédits donnés à la
sté générale à la nef au crédit mutuel
et ils peuvent se baser sur ce qu'il
veut soit sur leur ressenti soit sur des
rapports des ong qui nous disent que par
exemple dernièrement bébé a quasiment
alloué 40 % de ces crédits aux sociétés
très polluante
chacun a le droit de faire ce qu'il veut
pour essayer à sa petite échelle
d'essayer de changer le comportement des
banques par exemple quelqu'un qui s'est
fait refuser un crédit peut décider de
ne pas lever l'argent à sa banque à
l'huile à une autre banque une banque
qui serait trop dur avec ceux qui sont
toujours de toujours dans le rouge et
qui font ob d'énormes frais d'incident
ou d'agios peuvent se voir pénalisé par
les plus pauvres qui auraient le même
poids de décisions qu'un très très riche
et ça c'est une société de solutions
possibles qui permet justement d'être
plus équilibré et plus juste et c'est
une solution qui reprend encore une fois
les codes de la haute finance des fonds
spéculatifs
merci on peut on peut parfois comprendre
les inégalités lorsqu elle reflète une
réalité dans le travail et justement
comme vous avez expliqué la
financiarisation éloigne cette
légitimité des inégalités ont et creuse
même de gigantesques inégalités alors en
termes de solutions comment peut être on
peut repenser redonner sens et priaulx à
la valeur travail dans une société
nécessairement financiarisé en gros si
on regarde l'économie comme un gâteau ce
qu'il faut réfléchir c'est que chacun d
il ya une croissance de ce gâteau et il
faut réfléchir mais comment on va faire
pour répartir la croissance alors tout
ce qu'ils comprennent ce que c'est
qu'une exponentielle savent qu'à partir
d'un moment la part de gâteau qui en
surplus spa chaque année c'est à dire la
croissance va servir à payer le capital
est de moins en moins le travail jusqu'à
écrasé le travail c'est à dire que
depuis les années 80 donc on a ce petit
jeu j'ai envie d'appeler le kick off de
l'ex potentiel les horaires et ben on ne
voit que le capitaine a besoin par
construction de deux rémunérées la
oisiveté et non pas le travail alors
c'est intéressant parce que jusque en
2008 le capital oisifs parasitaire l'été
par les intérêts mais à cause de la
crise en a dû baisser fortement les
intérêts et s'est passé quelque chose de
très subtil c'est que c'est la création
monétaire par les banques centrales qui
a pris le relais
c'est à dire que la capitale parasitaire
est passé par la dette pour acheter des
actions et de l'immobilier pour toucher
des loyers et des dividendes
et donc on est vraiment dans ce cas de
figure c'est que les gens ils empruntent
à 0h est de l'immobilier achète du
commercial achètent des actions et
touchant dividendes du 3% et en
immobiliers entre du 2 et du cas tous
pour cent ça dépend de l'endroit de la
ville et avec de la tête levée à 0%
par exemple on est on est à des records
de chaire buy back aux états unis en
pourquoi parce que les sociétés se
disent m'attendais yann l'argent coule à
flots l'argent de la fed et nous on n'y
a accès en tant que multinationale
pourquoi n'emprunteraient pas à 0% et de
l'autre côté on rachèterait nos propres
actions eon les détruire et et on ferait
gagner à nos actionnaires
encore qu'ils sont fidèles n'ont pas
voulu vendre leurs actions encore plus
de dividendes sans rien faire sans
travailler voilà c'est vrai je rachète
10 % de mes actions avec de la dette
levée à 0% que je n'ai même pas besoin
de rembourser 1 parce que je peux la
relève en cinq ans et je joue manque de
10%
mon dividende mais pourquoi diable
devrais-je investir dans l'innovation
dans d'autres marchés qui sont instables
alors que je peux le faire par un tour
de passe passe financier comptable et
donc voilà c'est pour ça que le cheikh
bamba qui fonctionne pareil pour un
bernard arnault il est capable de lever
5 milliards d'euros 0 % faisant ça pour
acheter du tiffany
pourquoi ne le ferez team mais ce qui
est mauvais c'est qu'on nous vend la
fable que tout cet argent est censé
servir le travail c'est la création de
le combat contre le chômage et la
création de richesses et on le voit que
c'est pas vrai ça sert justement à une
petite minorité d'accumuler toujours est
toujours plus et le danger comme je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure c'est un danger de
pouvoir médiatique qui très politique et
ça me fait penser un petit peu au mythe
du du ruissellement 7
cette phrase exactement ça il s'est
vendu comme du riz seulement quand on va
sur la bce ils ont des desseins canton
de savoir ce que c'est que le
quantitative easing qe leur politique de
création monétaire c'est imprimantes
digital
il habite sa habilement quand élective
easing il veut le vendre comme du
ruissellement sauver saab rispal à
l'envers encore une fois j'ai revenir un
petit peu sur l'avenir de la finance
internationale parce que
qu'on a quand même conscience que c'est
un système très instable avec des dettes
qui s'accumulent qui attaque qui
atteignent des sommes astronomiques
je pense notamment aux dettes qui
s'accumulent aux états unis la dette
étudiante la fed qui imprime qui imprime
sans jamais s'arrêter
des sommes exponentielle est ce que vous
croyez que un effondrement du système
international financier puisse être
possible probable à l'avenir et comment
vous l'imaginez 6 il peut aussi peut
arriver à l'avenir
alors si la bce ou la fed n'avait rien
fait en deux minutes on aurait dû vivre
cet écroulement 2008 et donc les on
aurait eu des problèmes d'abord
financier bancaire et économique
énormément de chômage est c'est fait
avec de la création monétaire les
banques centrales ne font que reculer le
le problème parce que en fait ceux qui
sont élus politiquement mettre de la
pression aux banquiers centraux pour
l'heure résoudre leurs problèmes même
avec des ddd mauvaise solution hockey et
il repousse jusque le problème mais faut
bien comprendre c'est comme je le répète
souvent elle se perd rien ne se crée
tout se transforme
quand on crée de la dette pour répondre
à de la grette ont fait que repousser le
problème mais en crée d'autres problèmes
et les autres problèmes qui ont été
criés maintenant c'est un problème de
inégalités de richesse une instabilité
politique
voilà on est tous les populistes qui
sont arrivés au pouvoir et c'est fait
les gens sont frustrés les gens quand
ils sont contents il s'occupe pas de
politique quand ils sont frustrés ils
commencent à aller vers les plus
populistes avec la solution la plus
simple à se taper dessus à voir que
celle africain le mauvais celui qui a
ce qu'est sa vie pour venir qu'à travers
samedi dernier c'est le musulman c'est
le noir aux états unis va avoir de plus
en plus de troubles de fait il va
falloir que les gens va leur falloir la
retrouver justement des réponses à leurs
frustrations et je pense pas que les
réponses seront ne sera toujours la même
chose tout ce que je raconte là si par
exemple il ya un discours très connu de
joseph caillaux en 1932
c'est hallucinant il en train de re
expliqué l'époque dans laquelle on dit
il en train d'expliquer que la création
des terres cc c'est un poison sa
salariée en repousse us des problèmes et
que un moment si l'économie elle est
mortelle est mort ça rien de lui mettre
de la morphine mais joseph qu'il sait de
quoi il parle il a été sept fois
ministre des finances et j'invite tout
le monde à écouter sur youtube vous
tapez joseph caillaux sénat discours sur
la dette
voilà et il était très inquiet son
époque tout aussi tu as et donc on a vu
10 932 sept ans plus tard et la deuxième
guerre mondiale
alors je sais pas si ça prendra ses
tournures là on n'en sait rien mais
j'espère que les gens vont se bouger
parce que personne dans ce monde là est
capable de se bouger cirque on accepte
tout on accepte on accepte
moi je donne toujours l'image d'un tgv
qui roule à 300 à l'heure et qui va se
taper ans gars et on est tous là à
regarder à dire rien n'est possible
alors on est incapable de se bouger d'y
croire de 2-2-2 de dire il ya des
solutions il ya des solutions plus
équitable venez on réfléchit tous
ensemble et on peut arriver à des
solutions mais problème c'est que fauqué
de la volonté il faut pas que ça se
fasse dans la violence il faut que ça se
fasse par justement la discussion est
juste et le courage
les deux en même temps c'est à dire des
dépenses et innovante qu'on arrête
d'être dans le dans le dualisme
communiste ou néo libéral par exemple il
faut laisser les gens libres
d'entreprendre et en un temps leur
mettre des limites parce que le
néolibéralisme c'est
laisser aller laisser faire il n'y a
aucune limite c'est un peu l'idée des
physiocrates du xviiie siècle et de
turgot etc
c'est de dire bye ans on ne met aucune
limite à la cupidité humaine à l'avidité
on laisse faire la foule à la ruche
d'abeilles et n'en sortira que du miel
ça c'est un mythe aussi c'est à dire
qu'il faut entre la liberté individuelle
il faut aussi dire on va essayer de
faire en sorte que les richesses soient
distribués plus justement et que le but
ne soit pas que un citoyen écrase un
autre parce qu'il veut à tout prix créer
du rhône merci pour pour ses
explications on arriva à la fin de cette
entrevue est ce que éventuellement vous
auriez des ouvrages a conseillé à ceux
qui nous écoutent qui souhaitent
prolonger cette réflexion sur sur la
finance alors pour les celui que j'aime
bien ça va plaire aux gens mais c'est là
la bourse et la vie de jacques le goff
donc ce ça je pensais ça c'est un livre
un peu historique sur justement la
naissance de l'usure au moyen âge et je
pense permet d'aller vraiment à la
racine des problèmes c'est pour moi la
racine du capitalisme financier
son moteur c'est le crédit avec intérêt
justement ça s'est produit au moyen âge
c'est la libération de l'usure et je
pense que ce qui a manqué aux gens qui
voulaient défendre un monde sans cette
expo natalité 107 ces systèmes de dette
avec intérêt cette avance sur le temps
constante cette course contre le temps
ce qui leur a manqué c'est les idées jay
z
je pense que s'il y avait eu un gel aux
moyennes au moyen âge c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui pensait justement à la
fonte de la monnaie et au fait qu'il
fallait ramener la monnaie
à un niveau un peu plus humain
c'est-à-dire une monnaie qui se consomme
je pense si quelqu'un de du moins il n'a
jamais eu justement cette idée
magnifique et ben on n'en serait pas là
eh bien merci monsieur année cela
dépendra peut-être rester sur ce
conseiller lecture moins que vous en
ayez d'autres mais nous vous remercions
grandement pour cet échange très
instructif sur la finance internationale
et sur l'avenir on a essayé de terminer
l'entrevue avec des solutions innovantes
à apporter et qui pourront nourrir la
réflexion de chaque citoyen en plus vous
avez vous avez essayé de pousser les
citoyens à plus de monde d'hier de
courage et de volonté de s'inscrire
aussi dans une logique de combat et
c'est tout à votre honneur pour martiaux
énormément pour cet échange pour ses
réponses toujours très intelligente et
très très clair merci merci et s'il a un
dernier conseil voilà c'est eric
toussaint c'est pas le nom du livre en
tête mais eric toussaint c'est un
universitaire belge qui parle souvent de
la dette la dette que ce soit en
amérique du sud ou en afrique ou au
moyen-orient
je pense que c'est un auteur qui permet
justement de comprendre les mécanismes
merci également pour pour prolonger la
lecture on vous invite à aller aller
voir l'article détiennent sur notre site
scopeo la folie du système monétaire
international et également à regarder
éventuellement nos autres entrevues sur
notre chaîne youtube pour découvrir
notre travail qui essaye de prendre un
petit peu de hauteur sur des sujets
importants et je pense que la finance en
est un et qui sont peu traitée dans
l'espace médiatique et politique
et pourtant étant un sujet ô combien
politique
alors merci pour votre écoute et à très
bientôt sur scopeo l'observatoire
politique
merci à tous